downing street the heart of government
and now the most heavily fined address
in the country
the police today after five months of
work and nearly five hundred thousand
pounds call in time on their
investigation into covet lockdown
breaches and the judgment mass law
breaking across westminster and
whitehall in total we've made 126
referrals for a fixed penalty notice to
be issued
some of those referrals were for
more than one
fixed party notice to be issued 28
people
have been referred for between two and
five fixed penalty notices
were you surprised about the level of
fixed penalty notices given that these
people did write the laws
i think a number of people members of
the public have been both surprised and
concerned
what they have heard and i'm sure they
will be surprised and concerned about
the outcome of our investigation
has the prime minister broken the rules
the police investigation over next week
civil servant sue gray expected to
publish her report into lockdown
breaches
after that mps and the public will need
to make their own judgment many have
already made up their minds
one rule for one one rule for the other
so they're supposed to lead by example
aren't they so yeah
you lose faith there's a lot of people
that don't know my friends
and family all followed those rules
you know even with my mummy care home
because of boris johnson and what he
said and they go and do that no that yes
there should be more consequences
the labour leader himself subject to a
separate police investigation still
clear the prime minister who's received
one fine should go
my view of the premise hasn't changed of
course
after an investigation that says 120
plus breaches of the law in danistry of
course he should uh resign he's
responsible for the culture
he also needs to focus on the cost of
living crisis because
people are really struggling with their
bills inflation's up prices are up wages
are down after four months the police
investigation is now over and this
government emerges with the dishonor of
becoming the most fined
workplace in the uk it's astonishing
it's disappointing some would say it's
shameful and yet for the prime minister
in there he'll be feeling huge relief
today after avoiding any further fines
which would have obviously put more
acute pressure on him but it's not over
yet next week sue gray releases her
report into number 10 culture and the
prime minister's own conduct today at
least though a significant hurdle is
cleared
and a hurdle that his supporters for now
will be grateful for of course um those
uh thus who set rules get additional
scrutiny that's always understood and
some of these parties should not have
happened and the prime minister
acknowledged that he's apologized for
that he paid the fixed penalty for the
one event that that he was at others
will will pay theirs as well
there were failings um and we
acknowledge that we acknowledge the
anger that some people will feel
how much that anger cuts through will be
the next question for mps for now the
prime minister appears just about safe
beth rigby sky news westminster